20h voici notre estimation du résultat
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle
en tête Jacques Chirac 20% des voix
énormes surprises Jean-Marie Le Pen
semble devoir être le second avec 17 %
des voix l'élection présidentielle de
2002 intervient après 5 ans de
cohabitation entre le Premier ministre
socialiste Lionel Jospin et le président
de la République issu du RPR Jacques
Chirac tous deux sont donnés favoris
tout au long de la campagne le climat
politique est particulièrement tendu sur
fond d'affaires judiciaire et dans un
paysage politique très éclaté votre
premier commentaire Jean-Marie Le Pen
tout simplement après l'énoncé de ces
chiffres et bien je crois que c'est une
grande défaite des deux leaders de
l'établissement Monsieur Le Pen le
résultat de ce premier tour au soir du
21 avril 2002 est inédit dans la vie
politique française
puisqu’un candidat classé à l'extrême
droite réussit à se qualifier pour le
second tour d'une élection
présidentielle
pour nous militants on a vu ça comme une
récompense extraordinaire qui arrivait
après dans l'année de lutte parce que
c'était une lutte politique
c'est quand même un peu une surprise
assez curieusement d'ailleurs celui qui
l'avait le mieux prédit c'est LE PEN
lui-même je me souviens que 15 jours
avant l'élection nous sommes réunis en
bureau politique du Front national il
dit il faut quand même préparer une
campagne de deuxième tour parce que je
sens un frémissement et je pense qu'il
n'est pas impossible que je sois au
deuxième tour
la surprise est d'autant plus grande que
le Front national de Jean-Marie Le Pen
est très affaiblie depuis ce scission en
1998 le parti est au point mort la
plupart de ces cadres ont quitté le
navire
quand Jean-Marie Le Pen arrive au second
tour à la présidentielle il a la tête
d'un micro groupuscule pauvre avec
personne c'est totalement la demande
sociale la demande des électeurs qu'il
propulse au second tour tout le monde
reçoit à ce moment-là un énorme coup de
massue sur la tête Le Pen sera au second
tour personne ne veut grand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui est cet homme lucide à la tête de
l'extrême droite française qui arrive au
second tour de la présidentielle de 2002
souhaite-t-il vraiment prendre le
pouvoir
[Musique]
est-il en mesure de l'exercer d'où
vient-il quelle est sa personnalité
on considère que les gens de caractère
sont des gens qui ont mauvais caractère
et qui tranchent sur la platitude
générale non je pense bien sûr que les
difficultés de la vie
m'ont forgé comme tous les êtres humains
Jean-Louis Marie Le Pen et le fils
unique de Jean Le Pen marin-pêcheur
conseiller municipal de La
Trinité-sur-Mer et d'Anne-Marie Hervé
couturière et fille de paysans
[Musique]
son père trouve la mort à bord du
chalutier quand le bateau qui pêchait
saute sur une mine remontée dans son
chalut le 22 août 1942
[Musique]
un jour un Allemand est arrivé
devant la porte
il a dit un homme grosse valeur la
guerre mais
il est parti
en pleine figure
à ce moment il devient l'homme de la
famille c'est là qui garde le fusil de
son père un pistolet aussi nous sommes
qui cache dans dans le grenier avec le
drapeau français donc ça explique aussi
son son côté j'irai très patriote dans
patrie à père pour lui la nation c'est
le cadre effectivement qui va remplacer
qui va faire la famille donc on ne peut
pas comprendre le personnage sans cet
enfant et sans le fait que montant à
Paris faire les études il va aussi
devenir un jeune travailleur il y a cet
aspect là ce travail famille Patrick
dans son vécu dès son enfance
jeune diplômé voyant poindre la défaite
française en Indochine il s'engage dans
l'armée et Siran 1954 où il sert comme
sous-lieutenant quand je suis en
doctorat je pense que la vie ne se
déroule pas ici c'est ailleurs je pense
que c'est en attendant en Asie et je
m'engage je demande à partir
dans les parachutistes de la Légion
étrangère qu'est-ce qu'il voulait
défendre
est-ce que c'était l'Empire qu'il
voulait défendre ou est-ce que c'était
pas plutôt des jeunes qui avaient
encore le poids de l'humiliation de la
France en 1940 sur le cœur
à son retour d'Indochine en 1955 Le Pen
devient président des Jeunes
indépendants de Paris et délégués
général de l'union de défense de la
jeunesse française
[Musique]
présentée à Pierre Poujade il devient
délégué national de l'union de défense
des commerçants et artisans
UDCA
il est placé à la tête de la liste
législatives dans la première
circonscription de la Seine
la France à ce moment-là elle traversée
par un courant contestataire qui
ressemble un peu à celle du des gilets
jaunes si on veut
d'origine professionnelle l'union de
défense des commerçants et des artisans
alors aujourd'hui ça semble pas grand
chose parce qu'il y a quoi les artisans
et commerçants il en reste mais pas des
millions à l'époque c'était le avec les
paysans le gros de la population
française donc c'est une classe sociale
énorme qui sent qu'elle est menacée
la vague poujadiste lui permet d'obtenir
quelques 36 000 voix soit 7,8% des
suffrages exprimés
grâce au système de la proportionnelle
Jean-Marie Le Pen est élu à l'Assemblée
nationale à l'âge de 27 ans Le Pen qui
est un orateur brillant très jeune va
s'insérer là-dedans
et réussir très bien ça sera le plus
grand orateur du groupe
poujadis à l'Assemblée nationale
en octobre 1956 la guerre d'Algérie
ferrage
il quitte pour 6 mois les bancs de
l'Assemblée nationale pour s'engager
dans son ancienne unité
avec lequel il participe comme chef de
section au débarquement en Égypte à Suez
puis à la bataille d'Alger
moi je comme toutes les forces
politiques françaises à part le Parti
communiste était pour l'Algérie
française encore une fois un acte haut
en couleur un peu genre Le Pen mais mais
encore une fois courageux
cet engagement lui vaut d'être
récompensé de la Croix de la valeur
militaire par le général Massu
mais aussi une décennie plus tard
d'accusation d'actes de torture
[Musique]
lui son propos c'est j'ai défendu
l'usage de la torture qui me paraissait
pouvoir être légitime dans le cadre de
la guerre mais je ne l'ai pas pratiqué
et les biographes qui ont travaillé sur
le cas de Jean-Marie Le Pen n'ont pas
non plus trouvé d'éléments qui
permettent de dire oui il a fait non il
ne l'a pas fait
des accusations jamais étayées
et en novembre 1958 sous l'étiquette
indépendant de Paris du Centre national
des indépendants et paysans Jean-Marie
Le Pen est réélu député
à l'Assemblée il multiplie les prises de
position pour l'Algérie française et il
est entendu en novembre 1961 par la
police après s'être intervenu lors d'un
meeting où sont ovationnés l'OAS une
organisation terroriste de pro Algérie
française et le général félon Raoul
Le Pen est contacté pour faire partir de
l'OM
cette conspiration était tout simplement
mal ficée donc sans doute Jean-Marie Le
Pen a-t-il senti à l'époque pensant sans
doute par ailleurs
qui est en parlementaire il avait
peut-être d'autres moyens de servir la
cause de l'Algérie française que de
rentrer dans la conspiration j'ai
toujours refusé de m'engager dans une
dans de structures
j'étais obligé d'obéir à des gens que je
ne connaissais pas
candidat à sa réélection dans la
troisième circonscription de la scène
aux élections législatives de 1962 il
est défait dans le cadre d'une
triangulaire remporté par un candidat
gaulliste
dès 1963 il est nommé directeur de
campagne de l'avocat d'extrême droite
Jean-Louis Tixier Vignancourt en vue de
l'élection présidentielle de 1965
ils s'engage derrière Tixier Vignancourt
parce qu'il connaît ce qu'il y a en
cours et qu'il apprécie cet homme qui a
défendu pas mal de proscrit de
l'épuration d'abord et de partisans de
l'Algérie française en Suisse la France
avait un défaut absolu de présence
politique sur sa droite c'est ni
l'organisation
indépendante et paysannes
occupé le terrain disons des modéré mais
la France manquait à mon sens d'une voix
pour défendre son identité sa fierté sa
personnalité il y a une opportunité
professionnelle à saisir il n'est plus
par le long terme
et puis il y a aussi le fait qu'il a un
talent d'organisateur
[Musique]
il participe à la fondation des comités
Tixier Vignancourt dont il est le
secrétaire général de 1964 à 1966
[Musique]
il organise une campagne politique
originale et décalée pour l'époque
il est organisateur de la campagne qui
s'est mis en cours de ce qu'on a appelé
la caravane antixievignancourt qui
sillonnait les plages de France en plein
été pour tenter de rameuter des
électeurs
de cette campagne présidentielle il tire
de nombreuses leçons
sommes à l'expérience de la conduite
d'un mouvement politique la nécessité de
l'implantation locale
territoriale l'organisation
hiérarchique du mouvement
mais rien ne se passe comme prévu ils
rend finalement avec Tixier Vignancourt
à la suite du scrutin présidentiel lui
reprochant notamment un manque
d'autorité politique
[Musique]
après un nouvel échec au législatif de
1968 Le Pen se retrouve sans travail et
sans famille politique il se lance alors
dans l'édition de disque documentaire
dont une partie du catalogue est plutôt
sulfureuse
il fallait que aussi que je gagne ma vie
j'ai fondé une maison de production de
disques historique et
documentaire
qui a atteint une certaine notoriété
puisque j'ai même eu un grand prix du
disque alors que je n'étais pas personne
à gratin dans les milieux du showbiz
c'est loin qu'on puisse dire ni
d'ailleurs dans les autres il galérait
Jean-Marie Le Pen financièrement
presque il tâtonnait pas idéologiquement
parce que quand on ouvre le catalogue de
la serpe les catalogues de la serpe on
voit bien déjà
quelles sont ses orientations je pense
par exemple à certains disques
d'anciens wafone essai qui ont été
édités il a été condamné aussi pour une
publication donc il est dans son bain
à la fin des années 60 de nombreux
groupuscules d'extrême gauche ou
d'extrême droite font de l'agit de
propre dans les rues des grandes villes
françaises
à l'extrême droite environ 150 militants
créés en décembre 1969 un mouvement
appelé ordre nouveau
programme en 70 qui propose
l'instauration d'un État fasciste en
France avec l'interdiction des parties
l'interdiction des syndicats la croix
sceptique et leur emblème ils pratiquent
de temps à autre le salut fasciste et il
pratique la violence à grande échelle
ils seront dissous pour 82 acte de
violence de rue
le credo d'ordre nouveau était la
renaissance du patriotisme la promotion
du hiérarchie des valeurs ainsi que la
restauration familiale et éducative
l'objectif proclamé était de constituer
l'ossature d'un futur parti politique
ayant vocation à rassembler l'opposition
nationaleiste de droite et de participer
aux élections il se cherche une potiche
il trouve la potiche Le Pen donc Le Pen
arrive comme potiche en chef pour
parrainer les élections seulement Le Pen
n'a pas une tempérament de potiche et il
se trouve qu'il est très bonne orateur
il a toujours été très bonne amateur
donc il soulève les foules et les salles
et finalement c'est la potiche qui va
prendre le Front National et pas les
autres
une partie majoritaire des cadres et
jeunes militants d'ordre nouveau valide
Jean-Marie Le Pen comme leader politique
du Front national pour l'unité française
lancer le 5 octobre 1972 à Paris
ces statues sont déposés le 27 octobre
1972 à la préfecture de Paris par Pierre
Bousquet un ancien va fenêtre
[Musique]
la participation du Front national on a
assuré la logistique pour le Front
national
on faisait les actions médias et autres
bon c'est Le Pen qui est sorti du lot
parce que bon effectivement
charisme une culture extraordinaire on a
avalé Le Pen
[Musique]
dans la perspective des élections
législatives de 1973 le parti entreprend
de constituer un rassemblement de la
droite nationale alliant des anciens
pujadistes aux franges pétainiste ou
néo-nazis les plus extrêmes
rassemblez rassembler rassemblés c'était
ça quand même leitmotiv tout mon action
politique
dans un monde très hostile
le mouvement est apparu comme la seule
force organisée de l'opposition
nationale les dirigeants d'ordre nouveau
et inspirateurs du Front national
François Duprat et Alain Robert
s'inspire du modèle du MSI le parti
néo-fasciste italien fondé en 1946 par
des proches de Mussolini
se réclamant d'une droite sociale
populaire nationale le nouveau parti
français se veut être une troisième voie
entre lutte des classes et monopole
moi je disais qu'il n'y avait de force
politique réelle que la force nationale
et qu'il fallait donc organiser l'action
politique à partir de cette notion de
base ça a été l'histoire du Front
national il Barrie Le Pen ça a été de la
jouer parce que maléficions sur la durée
de labourrer le sillon inlassablement
vous ne ténacité pour ça il
lors de la présidentielle de 1974 il se
définit comme le seul candidat de droite
Jean-Marie Le Pen peine depuis si
longtemps que si j'avais 90 ans un
combat courageux et que nous respectons
mais il a sans aucune chance tandis que
Giscard d'Estaing lui et donc le Pen se
retrouve avec 0,74%, la claque intégrale
le bon moyen mnémotechnique ces
ressources en 74
cette inoubliable il tombe en dessous de
1% mais ça a l'avantage de le faire
connaître
et ça aussi l'avantage de le rendre
légitime comme représentant de du
courant politique je dis je ne céderai
pas je ne m'arrêterai jamais maintenant
quel que soit les résultats et j'ai
entamé alors là
traversé du désert qui va cesser que en
1984 une traversée du désert qui
s'annonce arbre pour le chef d'un parti
sans le sou
un homme Hubert Lambert rentier
millionnaire et pourtant peut-être en
train de changer le destin de Jean-Marie
Le Pen
il a fait de lui son héritier
Lambert est alors membre du comité
central du FN
selon son médecin Hubert Lambert et
fragile physiquement et
psychologiquement il passe ses journées
enfermées chez lui avec sa mère en
pyjama à boire et fumer
[Musique]
Hubert et sa maman m'ont choisi comme
légataire universel ce qui m'avait
d'ailleurs fait un sourire et dire
écoutez
Hubert
universel mais tu as 50 moins de mois
conséquent je ne compte pas de grand
risque toutefois il décède très
rapidement le 27 septembre 1976 à l'âge
de 42 ans il lex à fortune d'environ 18
millions d'euros et l'hôtel particulier
de montre tout à Jean-Marie Le Pen
héritage Lambert beaucoup de militants
rêvent à ce moment-là se disent enfin on
le parti va être riche on va pouvoir
travailler il faut bien voir il y a des
militants du Front national à l'époque
qui leur poche paye les rames de papier
pour éviter les tracts voilà limitant
sont très investis sur un parti qui est
très pauvre mais en fait le l'héritage
Lambert va rester un bien privé une
affaire privée mais c'était quand même
la volonté de Monsieur Lambert ça
de pouvoir donner à Jean-Marie Le Pen la
possibilité de faire de la politique
parce que Monsieur Lambert croyait tout
à fait dans sa possibilité de mener ce
combat pour la France et donc de lui
donner les moyens financiers de le faire
sans être dépendant de tel ou telle
lobby ou bien d'attendre vous savez très
bien que pour faire de la politique il
faut les moyens de le faire
à peine deux mois plus tard le 2
novembre 1976 un attentat à la bombe
détruit son domicile parisien les 20 kg
d'explosifs l'une des plus grosses
charges qui est connue Paris depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale détruisent toute
une partie de l'immeuble de 5 étages
l'attentat est revendiqué par un comité
antifasciste
je crois que la bombe avait été
l'intention criminelles
l'intention de tuer de faire disparaître
le Pen et sa famille est-ce que c'était
pour des raisons privées ou pour des
raisons publiques je ne sais pas
après des années de vache maigre
l'élection du socialiste François
Mitterrand à la présidentielle de 1981
change radicalement la donne politique
et les municipales de 1983 sont un
tournant historique pour le FN Le Pen
obtient 11,26% des suffrages dans le 20e
secteur de Paris
à Dreux le Front National qui fusionne
sa liste avec le RPR permettent à la
droite de remporter la mairie le
secrétaire général du FN Jean-Pierre
Stirbois en devient adjoint je crois que
j'ai dit tout ce que la majorité des
droits pensaient tout bas ce score est
cet alliance sont pour le Front national
leur première victoire électorale
d'importance petite brèche toute petite
brèche mais qui montre bien quand même
l'état d'esprit à l'époque de cette
droite qui a encore sous le choc de
l'arrivée au pouvoir des socialistes en
80 avec il faut le rappeler des
ministres communistes à une époque où
l'URSS n’est pas encore tombé et où le
PC c'est une courroie de transmission de
Moscou et cette droite elle est prête
effectivement à prendre tout le monde
dans une grande union des droites sauf
qu'elle commet une grosse erreur
psychologique c'est considérer que
finalement ces gens sont des débris
c'est des débris de l'histoire c'est ce
qui reste de la vieille extrêmement qui
sont pas très dangereux ils sont pas
très malins donc on va naturellement
nous les notables de cette droite qui a
une sorte de droit naturel à gouverner
les utiliser comme force d'appoint et
puis on aura naturellement le dessus
mais non en fait c'est le début des
premiers succès électoraux du Front
national qui nous mettaient tout de même
au rang des organisations politiques qui
devaient être prises en considération et
ça a été le début en quelque sorte du
développement
politique électorale du Front national
[Musique]
Jean-Marie Le Pen obtient un accès
croissant à l'espace médiatique
notamment avec son passage à l'heure de
vérité le 13 février 1984 sur demande du
président François Mitterrand
[Musique]
bonsoir depuis la fin de la guerre
d'Algérie vous êtes devenu Monsieur Le
Pen à marginal du jeu politique certes
quelques jours après l'émission le FN
enregistre un millier d'adhésions
quotidienne alors qu'il n'en recueilli
en moyenne que 15 jusqu'ici alors
aujourd'hui vous avez une existence
électorale vous faites partie de la
réalité de la société française c'est un
fait et c'est pourquoi je vous ai invité
ce soir il fait un sans faute et surtout
une espèce de mise en scène où il se met
debout et demande à la salle qui était
tous étais tout acquise d'observer une
minute de silence à la mémoire des
victimes du communisme
et à mon tour
tombé dans le monde sous la dictature
communiste et de avoir une pensée
fraternelle à l'égard des millions
d'hommes qui sont dans les camps et au
goulag moi je suis journaliste et je
continue à poser mes questions si vous
le voulez bien alors il y avait sur le
plateau mais journalistes mais qui
tenait plus rien du tout je voudrais
poser une question sur les
restructurations industrielles
humile de silence grandiose le lendemain
il y avait mais c'est pas une blague
j'ai vu les les milliers de demandes
d'inscription Front national
les élections européennes qui suivent en
juin 1984 fonctionne sur un mode de
scrutin proportionnel il permet au plus
petit parti d'être représenté
le résultat ne se fait pas attendre
Jean-Marie Le Pen est élu député
européen alors que Le Pen était avant à
0,74 il se retrouve aux élections de
juin 84 les européennes à 11% c'est 10
députés européens et là à ce moment-là
il est possible de mieux structurer le
mouvement de trouver des concours et ces
concours vont permettre d'améliorer
matériellement le siège du Front
National et puis de commencer à pouvoir
alimenter les permanents
c'est l'époque où apparaît le thème de
la préférence nationale une expression
française forgée en 1985 par Jean-Yves
Le Gallo
la préférence nationale c'est quand même
une bonne manière de limiter
l'immigration tout simplement en
supprimant les pompes aspirantes à
l'immigration en faisant en sorte que
celui qui rentre à un peu moins
d'intérêt à rentrer ça devient le
problème du FN mais donc on voit bien
1985 le parti était créé en 1972 et ce
qui va devenir la pierre angulaire de
son programme est en fait un apport
d'eau de courant politique Jean-Yves Le
Gallou il vient de la Nouvelle Droite
c'est quelqu'un pour lequel la question
de la nationalité est profondément
reliée la question de l'éminité
RPR
282 Front national 37 le 16 mars 1986
après le passage au scrutin
proportionnel pour les législatives
promesses de campagne de François
Mitterrand permettant opportunément
d'atténuer une défaite programmée le
Front national fait son entrée à
l'Assemblée nationale et constitue un
groupe de 35 députés
[Musique]
il décroche la timbale parce que là avec
les dix députés européens au régional
133 ou 134 élus et puis au législatives
un groupe de 35 députés donc là on passe
vraiment du stade embryonnaire et de la
fameuse traversée du désert à l'éruption
sur la scène politique
l'émergence du Front national sur le
devant de la scène politique française
pousse la droite à se positionner par
rapport à Jean-Marie Le Pen alors qu'un
certain nombre de cadres du Front
national vient des parties de droite ou
bien à travailler avec eux
[Musique]
j'ai vu en Rhône-Alpes des sections
entières du RPR qui m'ont rejoint qui
ont rejoint le Front national je pense à
la section du RPR de Vénissieux par
exemple 3e ville du Rhône
l'alliance semble désormais la suite
logique politique entre le Front
National et le RPR
Jean-Marie Le Pen il a l'espoir de
participer à une coalition des droites
en 1986
que Jacques Chirac l'appelle pour
devenir ministre de la défense du
gouvernement de cohabitation
évident pour tout le monde et c'est là
qu'on tombe sur Chirac Chirac tout seul
qui refuse absolument
le succès une force nouvelle toujours
attractive aux yeux de l'opinion à
provoqué un phénomène de rejet des
organisations existantes et une espèce
de pacte de diabolisation et de refus de
collaboration comme j'avais essayé de la
démontrer possible lors de l'élection de
86 justement en recrutant
à côté des Front national pour commander
des gens qui étaient très proches de
nous mais qui appartenait au milieu
libéraux de la droite classique en
quelque sorte et la réaction nous a été
hostile et c'est traduite évidemment par
un blocage de notre progression
politique
Jacques Chirac il a senti tout de suite
que le Front national ne se destinait
pas un rôle de supplétif et que ces gens
si on sait liés avec eux c'était le
baiser de la mort
[Musique]
pourtant Le Pen travaille dur à
l'amélioration de son image en vue de la
présidentielle de 1988
il rencontre des personnalités
étrangères aux États-Unis Ronald Reagan
dont il se veut le panda français
il se fait même applaudir par d'anciens
membres du Congrès juif mondial pour un
discours pro israélien
cette campagne est immédiatement remise
en cause le 13 septembre 1997 lorsqu'il
affirme que les chambres à gaz sont un
détail de l'histoire de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale je suis passionné aussi
par l'histoire de la deuxième guerre
mondiale je me pose un certain nombre de
questions et je ne dis pas que les
chambres à gaz n'ont pas existé
je n'ai pas pu moi-même en voir je n'ai
pas étudié spécialement la question mais
je crois que c'est un point de détail de
l'histoire de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
[Musique]
c'est tout caractère de Jean-Marie Le
Pen il va refuser de se dédire il va au
contraire en rajouter il va répéter et
répéter le point de détails
de l'histoire
ce qui est une évidence
si c'est pas un détail de l'histoire
c'est quoi comme on dit comment peut-on
l'apprécier l'histoire est faite de
multiplicité de détails dans certains
sont essentiels dont on secondaire mais
qui constitue l'ensemble il y avait
absolument aucune affirmation politique
au contrat je traite-t-elle à faire avec
un relatif des daim je me demandais ce
que venait faire cette affaire dans le
débat qui nous intéresse c'est un point
de détail de l'histoire de la deuxième
guerre mondiale ces propos maintenus
aujourd'hui entraîne alors le départ de
sympathisants de militants et cadres du
Front national ainsi que la réprobation
de la quasi-totalité de la classe
politique
pour moi c'est très simple il n'a plus
jamais été en position de vraiment
parvenir au pouvoir parce que
l'exclusion qui a été signifié avant
trouver là une justification
colossale et là après si vous voulez
pour rétablir
un minimum de confiance de crédibilité
vis-à-vis de la droite dite par le
Nanterre aux conservatrices il faut y
aller à la RAM parce que très clairement
la question du point de détail a été une
sorte de ligne rouge qui rendait
véritablement l'hypothèse d'une alliance
même locale avec les parties de droite
strictement à faire
au soir du premier tour le 24 avril 1988
il obtient 14,4% des voix un score bien
supérieur à ce que lui accorder les
sondages Jean
-Marie le 14
ce score inattendu mes Chirac dans une
situation délicate
c'est essentiel traumatiser le monde
politique et censé dévoiler la
fascideuse la fascisme renaissant etc
etc mais monsieur Chirac rencontrera
Jean-Marie Le Pen entre les deux tours
sans
se souvenir du détail ou sans lui
accorder la moindre importance la
priorité étant que Le Pen appelle à
voter contre François Mitterrand
extrêmement nerveux et avant même toute
chose il dit voilà je ne peux pas
accepter ça ça et ça si vous voulez
accepter ni ça ni sa Nissan en effet il
n'y a absolument aucune raison que nous
ayons quelques contacts que ce soit par
conséquentation non pour vous servir
d'un Libye voilà ça amenait une
politique de non coopération
nous avons besoin d'un homme qui a les
idées claires Jacques Chirac a besoin
des voix de Le Pen pour l'emporter face
à François Mitterrand sans pour autant
conclure un accord formel côté RPR on
laisse entrevoir impossible retour d'une
dose de proportionnelle en échange d'un
appel à ne pas voter Mitterrand search
Chirac ne sera pas élu mais Le Pen lui
tiendra sa parole son discours est très
clair il dit
non non pas une voix pour François
Mitterrand voilà et il ajoute quand au
candidat résiduel de la droite faites ce
que vous voudrez sous votre
responsabilité alors candidat résiduel
de la droite il est bien certain que les
électeurs n'ont pas été tentés de
soutenir Jacques Chirac qui sera
évidemment battu et François Mitterrand
et lui a plus de 53%
les scrutins la proportionnelle ou
incluant une dose de proportionnelle ne
feront jamais leur retour
l'adversaire nous a mis tous les bâtons
possibles dans les roues et en
l'occurrence n'a jamais rétabli la
proportionnelle qui permettait aux Front
national d'exister sur le plan national
de faire connaître ses idées ses choix
ses opinions ces solutions et donc la
stériliser en quelque sorte
en conséquence le Pen change
radicalement de stratégie vis-à-vis de
la droite classique ça va permettre à Le
Pen pas de se venger de la parole trahie
au niveau de la proportionnelle et là
tout en continuant de participer aux
élections il va avoir un combat beaucoup
plus fort contre la droite et contre la
gauche c'est à dire c'est plus la
volonté d'être une force d'appoint la
droite là c'est une troisième force qui
n'hésitera pas à faire battre des
candidats de droite dans certaines
circonstances
après avoir été membre du RPR puis
présider son propre mouvement les
comités d'action républicaines Bruno
Maigret rejoint le Front national en
Jean-Marie Le Pen le nomme directeur de
sa campagne présidentielle pour 1988 et
son influence ne cesse de grandir au
sein du FN en octobre 1988 il est nommé
délégué général du Front national
[Musique]
tout à fait fréquentable il a occupé une
foule des fonctions qui correspondait à
ses capacités mais il y a effectivement
chez Maigret une capacité d'ordre de
réflexion de mise en langue des dossiers
d'organisation des blocs qui est très
bonne c'était un binôme qui fonctionnait
fort bien vous aviez le le général en
chef et le chef d'état-major en plus il
est l'équipe efficace je veux dire que
l'argument je vais professionnaliser le
Front national comme il n'a jamais été
il met en place effectivement des
structures à la fois intellectuelles et
techniques qui n'existait pas
en juin 1989 Maigret était élu au
Parlement européen à partir d'octobre
1990 il est de surcroît le leader du FN
dans la région Provence-Alpes-Côte
d'Azur
[Musique]
Jean-Marie Le Pen a toujours su à la
fois équilibrer les courants du parti
par exemple à la formation il met le
chef de fil des nationaux catholiques et
le chef des films des néopagnes ensemble
deux courants complètement opposés
travaillant ensemble et en même temps je
suis utilisé les uns contre les autres
Jean-Pierre Stirbois avait pris un
gigantesque poids dans le parti
Jean-Marie Le Pen lui met Bruno Maigret
dans les pattes quand Bruno Maigret va
monter à un moment Jean-Marie Le Pen va
jouer car langue il est l'arbitre qui a
organisé l'équilibre mais si vous prenez
trop de place il vous met quelqu'un dans
les pattes
peu à peu Bruno Maigret s'impose comme
numéro 2 du Front National et forge son
image ainsi ils font dans 1989 la revue
identité qui va organiser et mettre en
forme le corpus idéologique de l'extrême
droite française
[Musique]
Renault Mégret a réellement mis en place
à l'intérieur de l'appareil frontiste
ses propres réseaux
répondante à leur propre objectif
stratégiques qui ne sont pas toujours
convergents avec ceux que Jean-Marie Le
Pen Jean-Marie Le Pen fait une erreur de
psychologie il pense que Maigret ne
passera pas à l'acte au courant de tout
évidemment des projets de Maigret du
noyau de tâche de l'intervention dans
les organisations à un niveau de plus en
plus élevé la maîtrise de l'appareil
ainsi de suite mais à cette époque d'une
part
Jean-Marie Le penche avait incontesté et
d'autre part il pense que médaille n'a
aucune chance de réussir son opération
et donc il est assez intelligent pour ne
pas la tenter voilà et jusqu'au bout
Jean-Marie Le Pen je pense à cruche là
c'est que Maigret comprendrait qu'il ne
peut pas affronter Jean-Marie Le Pen et
s'en sortir
il y a un affrontement larvé entre les
deux hommes au sujet des concessions
qu'impliquent l'adoption pleine et
entière d'une stratégie de conquête du
pouvoir
Bruno Maigret propose pour y arriver une
alliance avec le RPR et l'UDF à la
condition que le FN soit en position
dominante
[Musique]
Bruno Maigret a fait espérer
le pensait sans doute d'ailleurs
lui-même que lui parviendrait à
s'entendre avec le RPR et l'UDF il a
fait miroiter un certain nombre de cas
si vous êtes conseiller municipal vous
allez devenir un élu départemental ou
régional c'était lui régional vous allez
devenir député etc Il a il a à partir de
qualité absolument indéniable
entraîner beaucoup de gens dans cette
opération
j'entends mais pour le père la seule
voie possible et celle de Le Pen c'est à
dire l'élection du chef à la
présidentielle que nous voulons c'est la
puissance Jean-Marie Le Pen considérait
que oui FN n'y avait pas numéro 2 en
numéro 1
et ça c'est sans doute une erreur
l'autre erreur je crois qu'il l'a
commise en pensant que le pouvoir ne
pouvait se conquérir que par le haut
dans les vraies divergences de
fonds entre Le Pen et mes grès en dehors
d'une différence de style ou
incontestable il y avait le poids à
donner à l'enracinement territoriale ou
pas plutôt Maigret était plutôt de ce
côté là Jean-Marie Le Pen était quand
même l'homme de l'élection
présidentielle qui était un peu présenté
comme la mère des batailles mesdames
messieurs bonsoir La pré-municipale avec
l'enracinement du Front national
symbolisé par la prise pourtant c'est
aux municipales de 1995 que le FN
s'envole pour la première fois il
obtient des mairies à Toulon à Orange et
Marignane
les réussites et les succès qu'il y
avait au niveau local et qu'il ne
suivait pas au niveau national voici le
choix des français même si Le Pen
améliore sensiblement son score à la
présidentielle de 1995 il arrive
seulement en quatrième position avec 15%
des voix derrière Lionel Jospin Jacques
Chirac et Édouard Balladur le temps
passe
il a 67 ans en 1995
et il comprend très bien que là il va en
prendre pour 7 ans de Chirac que donc il
aura 74 ans à la prochaine échéance
fort de ses succès Maigret amplifie son
emprise sur le FN et commence à presser
l'entourage de Le Pen pour qu'il passe
enfin la main
cette qualife à la place du calife un
peu quand même mais c'était sans
connaître Jean-Marie Le Pen parce que ça
pouvait ça Couvet quand même
bon il y avait quand même des approches
des uns et des autres qui étaient faites
très habilement je dois reconnaître mais
au bout d'un moment vous vous demandiez
quand même mais pourquoi il me demande
tout ça
on essayait de faire critiquer quand
même la façon de gérer le parti par
Jean-Marie Le Pen on le traitait
d'autoritaire et puis on disait mais
quand même à son âge alors vous voyez on
imagine aujourd'hui bon quand même son
âge il devrait passer la main déjà à
l'époque je pense que Bruno Maigret
considérait que la dernière campagne de
Jean-Marie Le Pen devait être 1995 et
que son tour viendrait à Renault Mégret
en 2000 en 2002
donc il fallait faire quelque chose
entre temps et puis Jean-Marie Le Pen
avait franchi l'âge symbolique de 65 ans
et pour les fonctionnaires 65 ans c'est
la retraite
il met en oeuvre une stratégie de
dédiabolisation pour permettre
l'accession au pouvoir il se montre
ouvert à des alliances avec la droite
parlementaire dans le même temps
Jean-Marie Le Pen perd le soutien de
plusieurs cadres du parti qui regrette
son manque d'implication dans les
élections législatives et locales qui
vous réussissez à amener la droite à
signer les contrats de mandatures et
bien vous voulez victimez vous voulez
victimer
d'autant plus si vous savez ensuite
montrer que vous pouvez être des
gestionnaires corrects
vous voulez jeter si vous réussissez
être à la fois
dans une certaine forme de radicalité
politique et si en même temps vous
réussissez à naviguer entre les écueils
de politiquement correct et ça
Jean-Marie Le Pen c'est pas faire je
n'étais pas en position de subir ces
exigences
internes en mouvement de qui que ce soit
à aucun moment j'avais une autorité
dans le mouvement qui ne permettait pas
de faire quoi que ce soit en dehors de
mon accord de mon autorisation
[Applaudissements]
le conflit se cristallise autour des
élections européennes de 1999
de passer à l'acte
la crise atteint son paroxysme le 5
décembre 1998 lors du Conseil national
qui réunit les 300 responsables les plus
importants du parti pour préparer les
européennes
[Musique]
les mégrittes font éclater la
contestation au grand jour et qu'on se
pue le Pen Jean-Marie tout déconnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était pas une journée marrante le 5
novembre
98 loin de là
quand on est arrivé à cette grande
réunion à la Maison de la Chimie
c'est vrai que vous sentiez à l'arrivée
que il y avait un truc qui allait se
passer quand même parce que les gens
c'est venu faire des sens
il y avait une violence sous-jacente
déjà bon et puis voilà ça s'est
déclenché et Le Pen à ce moment-là
réagit
c'était qui tout double
c'était qui est tout doux parce que
quand vous avez un putsch poutch enfin à
l'époque ça ressemblait quand même un
putsch tout court qui se passe en direct
comme ça vous savez pas qu'elle va être
l'issue bon et le peigne là là réagi
alors vraiment à sa façon c'est à dire
de façon extrêmement claire bon les foot
en dehors
cela provoque la révocation de Maigret
de la Délégation générale du parti puis
son exclusion le 23 décembre 1998 pour
le FN de l'Open c'est une saignée
ce qui fait que voilà il y a eu cette
fission qui était une véritable
catastrophe pour le franc parce que d'un
côté le Pen reste avec son nom avec sa
gueule avec son histoire avec ses
capacités et donc le gros des électeurs
va aller à Le Pen et l'autre côté vous
allez cadre l'organisation qui va avec
mes graisses donc cette espèce
d'équilibre de front
est complètement rompu bettera des
années et des années
600 n'est jamais remis parce qu'à mon
avis il s'en est pas remis
après ces dérapages des années 80 et 90
cette scission hypothèque de nouveaux
sérieusement sa prochaine candidature à
l'élection présidentielle même si
l'ancien leader du Front national ne
regrette rien
la rupture du Front a été un coup
terrible mais je ne regrette pas d'avoir
eu les positions que j'ai eu à ce
moment-là
sur le plan électoral la sanction est
immédiate aux européennes qui suivent le
parti de mes graines ne dépasse pas les
quatre pour cent tandis que Le Pen ne
parvient à faire élire que 5 députés
et tout cela est débouché sur un gâchis
monumental c'est-à-dire des résultats
très mauvais pour les deux mouvements le
front à 5% aux européennes en 99
maisgré
3%, mais Le Pen restera sonné par cette
scission dans la mesure où il retrouvera
jamais l'implantation qui avait fait des
heures de gloire du Front national dans
les années 90
[Applaudissements]
fort de ces mauvais résultats et d'un
parti exemples la surprise est d'autant
plus grande pour les observateurs et le
principal intéressé
cette élection constitue un événement
important dans la vie politique
française c'est la première fois qu'un
candidat classé à l'extrême droite se
qualifie pour le second tour en direct
de son quartier général mais le
traditionnel débat d'entre-deux tours
n'a pas lieu Jacques Chirac refuse de
débattre avec lui et près de 500 000
Français décembre dans la rue
mais au-delà de ces événements Le Pen
était-il vraiment mesures de prendre le
pouvoir
vous faites 17% des voix à la
présidentielle ou excédez au second tour
vous avez fait le plein de vouvoie vous
avez dans la population française dans
l'électorat français c'était
la présidentielle c'est 50% des voix
plus une pour la gagner et le rapport de
force y est pas alors effectivement on a
pu dire et c'est une réalité que Le Pen
lui-même n'avait pas anticipé sa
présence au second tour que le parti
n'avait pas de matériel de campagne pour
le grand tour dans les tiroirs que la
machine n'était pas assez puissante pour
mettre le turbo entre les deux tours
mais ça aurait pas changé grand chose de
toutes ces sourcils l'avaient eu la
vérité c'est quand vous êtes une famille
politique qui représente 0 en 1974 et
que vous êtes à 17% en 2002 vous avez
déjà fait un énorme travail et vous avez
atteint votre plafond
faiblesse structurelle plafond de vote
et le candidat voulait-il le pouvoir
il croyait-il vraiment
était-il prêt à rassembler le plus grand
nombre
[Musique]
Jean-Marie Le Pen a-t-il voulu le
pouvoir moi je crois que oui je crois
qu'il l'a voulu ardemment en 65
il l'a voulu
84 86 87 jusqu'à l'élection 95
il a été
scié par l'élection de Chirac qui était
l'homme qui a actualisé le piège de
Mitterrand sans Chirac le piège de
Mitterrand ne marche pas je pense qu'à
partir de 95
je ne sais pas consciemment si c'est dit
allez je vais jouer pour ne pas avoir le
pouvoir mais je crois qu'il a perdu
l'espoir d'arriver au pouvoir et qu'il a
donc continué à jouer le rôle d'un très
bon chef de partie par moment d'autres
fois moins bon c'est après on discute ou
pas mais oui c'est la cassure c'est 95
si pour élargir la base des électorales
il faut changer les idées que l'on croit
juste en effet je ne suis pas
suffisamment
manœuvrié suffisamment malin et c'est
surtout je n'ai pas comme objectif
principal mon succès personnel dans ce
cas donc je le fais pas
sacrifice de principe au bénéfice de
succès électoraux voilà néanmoins
j'assume la responsabilité
des échecs éventuels qui peuvent être
liées au respect de certains nombre de
valeurs que je considère comme un
contournable
on entend souvent de Le Pen que l'homme
n'a pas gagné mais que ces idées en
triompher qu'elles imprègnent
aujourd'hui la société française
[Musique]
Jean-Marie Le Pen à part entièrement
gagné la bataille des idées la France
est toujours dans l'Union européenne
nous accueillons encore des demandeurs
d'asile il existe encore une immigration
légale et un certain nombre de réformes
sociétales ont vu le jour donc non les
idées n'ont pas triompher et puis
d'autres idées sont apparues aussi que
les jeunes générations non frontiste
portent et que le Front national
n'arrive pas à capter notamment les
sujets liés à l'urgence environnementale
mais la petite musique
sur l'immigration et sur l'identité oui
incontestablement et là largement
contribué à faire qu'aujourd'hui ces
thèmes soient repris non seulement par
ceux qui constituent à l'extrême droite
mais même à l'intérieur de la droite
cinq fois candidats de l'extrême droite
à une présidentielle Le Pen s'est tissé
par trois fois en quatrième position du
premier tour puis à la surprise générale
au second tour de celle de 2002
[Musique]
sa fille Marine Le Pen lui succède en
2011 à la présidence du parti dont il
devient président d'honneur avant d'en
être exclu en 2015
Le Pen a été la figure de proue du Front
national un assemblage de constellations
politiques complexe aux intérêts aux
idéaux parfois contradictoires
mais aussi un trait d'union entre
diverses familles de l'extrême droite
des admirateurs de Vichy aux catholiques
intégristes nationalistes en passant par
les nostalgiques de l'Algérie française
jusqu'aux anti communistes ou défenseurs
délaissés pour compte de la modernité
[Musique]